welcome back to the Jenna Julia but
guess where we're not tired today it
feels good to like be a little bit awake
I'm exhausted tired I think I think it's
because we've been we've been up for a
little while and we've like been
productive you know I mean like it's not
a weekend it's like a weekday yeah so I
kind of feel like in the zone in reality
I'm exhausted but I feel good and I'm
well you can be tired tomorrow ready to
dink it up my basketball game I'm
leaving for the airport for the fog it's
less than 12 hours from now
oh my god don't say that to me I'm sorry
why do you come at me like that girl
sorry I'm gonna have to wake up and take
my lift and right now you can drive for
a lift they're looking for new drivers
sighs do you like being able to earn
hundreds of dollars per week keeping
100% of your tips and easy pickups drive
for lyft right now if you go to ly
ft.com so that's Jenna Julianne you
score yourself a $500 new driver bonus
trust me is a great gig great people
lyft is awesome all right
that's how ride-sharing should be go to
lift comp / annejulien and get started
limited time only make sure you check it
out something since when did you start
like segwaying in the beginning of the
podcast though this is like the third
week in a row that you've segwayed in
the beginning there's only so many
moments per episode that I can fit
segues in and sometimes I have more
segues in the tank and then I have room
for on the podcast so I've been creating
more space got it sick
creating tight creator featured creator
Oh
Julia's gonna buffer festival in the
morning he's going to Toronto I'm gonna
miss you I miss you by the time people
are watching this I'm gonna be back in
your arms bit yeah I know I I'm excited
I'm also I'm also preemptively already
missing you but you know it'll be good
buffer fest is a good time and we're
premiering our short film which would be
fun you can have fun yeah be painting
right with Rome and Colin I'm going to
throw me in Colin
waffle in a Rome I've never traveled or
even really been with just the two of
them I know it's gonna be a while it's
like how Rome always travels with you
and I you're gonna travel with Rome do
you think they're gonna annoy me like
Roman Oh like we annoy Rome probably god
damn but we need to get her back home we
need to get room back in our home home
court advantage okay
she's due for some messing with it the
video that I posted where you passed
that note from when she was on the
podcast which is like oh it says you're
a dirty [ __ ] no way she got you so good
anyways Julian what are we doing today
so we have a couple things planned Jenna
initially came with this idea and I kind
of perfected it
it's called clickbait roulette and what
we're doing with this game which i think
is really funny is we basically broke
down clickbait into three categories
right here you have the video category
okay that's like the disclaimer or what
the type of video is whether it's in the
title or not this is like a story time
video or a vlog it's like this is what
categorizes the video so I've made 21
different video categories then over
here we have the dramatic title which
what is what makes clickbait so great
the dramatic title so that there's drama
in the title describing what's happening
in a very dramatic and likely lying way
I have 21 different dramatic events
listed in title form and then lastly we
have who who is it happening to is that
are they gonna be like all jumbled cuz
it's the first time like usually when we
do this kind of thing like we both write
them together I did this myself Julie
like is this gonna work like what if the
subject is totally different than the it
will likely not work at all but we're
here and we're we're ready to go no I
think it'll be good I honestly do
because I was like mixed I was mixing
matching them like wow I was doing it
see make sense and it works okay like
keep in mind is the general practice and
be incredibly [ __ ] I like make little
to no sense I'm like a little nervous
because usually we write this stuff
together so I like have some idea of
what some of them are I literally have
no idea what any of those say I like it
William jealous at all I like it when
you're nervous
meanwhile in the second half of the pie
caste I took it upon myself to peruse
some of Craigslist missed connections
and pull out some of my favorite ones
they're not even like famous ones of all
time they're just like in the last few
days recent yeah you can find good ones
in la la
well like greater LA so in some Orange
County ones in there too so today it's
gonna be the Julian podcast and then the
Jenna podcast basically each have a
podcast for you today
yes but I don't know how we're gonna do
like the ranking system with the
clickbait through let I was thinking we
can just let go and then like like maybe
I make one you make one and then the
winner sighs let's decide who wins okay
all right are you ready yeah all right
so you got to pick one of each and I'll
pick one of each the suspense is killing
me
wait please yeah type them out you type
them in Princes yeah there's so little
they're perfectly sized okay I just want
to make sure you don't mess these up
okay category is fall favorites no there
comes at the end the category comes at
the end oh well then why don't you do it
this way oh sorry all right so then what
comes first automatic title who what and
then category okay why don't you
organize the cups that way I'm not the
Virgo okay here we go
my assistant got lost and almost starved
fall favorite okay fine you these these
were created out of clickbait real life
clip bands person that i went and found
on youtube my dead parakeet accidentally
sent nudes to michael pencil unboxing oh
my god I'm sorry but those are [ __ ]
trump cards how do you unbox anything in
that title like how you put the stars
around unbox emotional
all right so this one wins absolutely my
dad my dead parakeet accidentally sent
nudes - Michel pencil which for those of
you who don't remember that podcast it
was a tweet that I [ __ ] like I
laughed for like 10 minutes at it that's
really Mike Pence is short for Michael
pencil all right we got a winner oh my
god I'll put the winners yes you're
crushed mine those are the losers over
there what the hell okay I don't I want
I got a lot of good I got a lot of good
ones in here Ben Ben there's a lot of
good stuff my dead parakeet all right
I'll go first though okay
Guy Fieri this is nicely perfect guy
Yeti eating 50,000 calories in one hour
boobs in thumbnail I have my daddy
proposed to her while skydiving reaction
I can already see that thumbnail like
it's just some idiot photoshopped in
front of a skydiver saying bye daddy
with a ring reaction that was pretty
good okay no yours is still yours and
thumbnail if anything I feel like this
is like creative fuel for those of you
out there that just want to make the
greatest clickbait in the world coz
clickbait any easy okay you need more
inspiration creativity it's like bait
market you got to get creative more
click baby more fat so Guy Fieri eating
50,000 calories in one hour boobs in
thumbnail yes that's the one perfect all
right - I know baby I don't understand
how that video could have any less than
20 million views trended first a week's
- yet like there's no way I like this
game already
it's pretty fun yeah it's funny cuz it's
real so yeah are you read the first one
okay I have oh my god my idiot dog fell
asleep driving what I ate
today I'm into like what I ate what I
eat in a day when I eat in a day it's
pretty good my butthole was sentenced to
drug the sentence of death for
trafficking drugs live footage yes no
I'm getting lucky I'm literally picking
them out of the cup gosh I can't believe
I cannot believe my butthole got paired
with sentenced to death for trafficking
drugs are you kidding me
that's a match made in heaven live
footage I love when they include live
footage in the title but half them don't
even have life no that's the greatest
part it's like you see that face I
wonder will it be live footage yeah 30
minute video of them explaining a live
footage and then it's like you know a
grainy 10-second video of like around
the area like no actual live footage
whatsoever like okay guys so that was
the live footage so as you can see
everything that I said is it completely
true and you're like [ __ ] what the [ __ ]
what do you think the live photos would
look like for this video my butthole was
sentenced to death for trafficking drugs
live footage I mean how would they end
up posing at if their bottle got
sentenced is it live footage of the
sentencing or a you championing cause or
do I win again yeah you wouldn't get
sorry that I'm picking better cards than
you babe this is random okay I'm gonna
make do with what you got I think you're
looking at that I'm not are you kidding
me am I being accused I was accused
about my girlfriend
story time okay what what is wrong with
me all right you go first all right I
have that one [ __ ] boy is adopted ASMR
um my turn my step hamster got doxxed
well naked top ten how can mine win no
I'm getting a Mars incredible Mars gonna
I like I like the fact that you're like
expose
someone has being adopted but you don't
even include their name like that one
[ __ ] boy yeah how is it an ASMR though
somehow yes make sure you leave a like
on the video before it say anything like
the video again I know you just did it
but do it again and it refresh again
follow me flag this video please I like
I really genuinely hope that people
understand when people are like oh in
order to win this whatever stupid
probably fake prize that they're giving
away some of them should be [ __ ]
illegal but like when they're like
follow me on this this and this in order
to enter is a chance to win there's no
way for them to check that no way to
verify that you don't mean in no way
they're like you need to follow me like
this tweet and on like other platforms
there's no way to check that there's no
way correct
it's so manipulative yes it is okay this
is a little off-topic but did you hear
that thing where Taylor Swift was uh
selling tickets to her upcoming tour
whatever and she was like for the super
fans out there that want like faster or
earlier access or like a better chance
of like getting access to tickets as
soon as they come out just go watch look
what you made me do as many times as you
can to increase your chance drag views
exactly but like I've read that on
Twitter or something in Twitter moments
like a couple days after the video came
out the music video not the lyric video
and I was like this is this is like
actually criminal yeah you're I'm pretty
sure that that violates with with the
bribe of rewarding those who are
throttling the views but there's no
there's no actual way to test who's
doing that no way isn't that insane yeah
so like her video has the music video
has like four hundred and thirty
something million and then the lyric
video has like seven
million or something I know this only
because I just said my radio show today
but it has almost half a billion views
but a lot of them were like manipulated
into getting you know what I mean that's
[ __ ] up isn't it but I feel bad for
these like 13 year olds that are sitting
in their room refreshing your music and
yeah they're gonna get it yeah I think
they're gonna have a better choice when
winning reality there's a literal zero
percent chance that they will get it
yeah isn't that [ __ ] yeah that's
that's pretty [ __ ] okay anyways that
one [ __ ] boy is adopted I like that much
no it doesn't yours wins I'm winning
again I'm for now yeah step you're
picking up out of the cup game look what
you made me do anyways if you guys want
a fact check what I just said I hope
that that's what happened because that's
what I thought I wrote or if she changed
it or did something differently but I
know that she was facing criticism for
doing that because it's so [ __ ] wrong
and manipulative and a flat-out [ __ ]
lie really pissed me off
what wait I gotta pick my last one for
me oh really
okay my stepdad had an allergic reaction
and peed out of my bucket exposed peed
out of my butt I don't know okay you
know might don't look sorry my mom STD
test came back positiv Q&A that's [ __ ]
mines funny enough there's no way that
that doesn't win of course that wins I'm
five I know baby
my dad had an allergic reaction in
PETA's but exposed yeah alright how
about for the next one you pick both
both of ours oh no no you pity win no no
I'm not saying you pick I'm saying to
make it just so you know it's fair you
pick my cards and then pick yours no I
don't want to do that these pieces of
paper are too little they are pretty
little why did you do they're adequate
okay I would click that [ __ ] video
I'll click on my stepdad had an allergic
reaction my wait what's the allergic to
peanuts tree nuts dates shellfish dates
things Wow
cooked of dates how does how does one
pee out of someone else's but I watch it
click live footage lively expose mine is
Barack Obama got hacked livestream it's
too realistic yeah that's bad that
wasn't already fresh literally just an
ant I found on the sidewalk got arrested
again crying in thumbnail why am I
getting all the gold ones why is this
happening like this is ridiculous I
don't know like who's crying the fund
anything to aunt the aunt just it's a
photoshopped picture of an aunt like a
stock photo movie ants yeah and then
they like morph it Jack's film style
like so it brings his cheeks down so
he's crying yeah okay so seven six and
oh wow the one time that I don't read
any that's what you get we can do around
to this sometimes someday it's gonna be
hard though why cuz I'm me it was hard
to think of the video categories for 21
different ones I'll go first go for it
you're gonna win I married a prostitute
boyfriend tag even better that's even
better
why you keep getting such moons oh the
subject you like video is just eyes yeah
married a prostitute boyfriend that's
amazing
alright mine is my landlord is pregnant
with an alien spawn baby district
I quit you can't quit I can't quit I
quit I'm sorry that I'm my hands are
like magnets of gold gold
it's like attracting goals with myth
magnets like if gold was magnetic my
hands are the magnet it's what I'm
trying to say
I'm just moving over the cup and then
called minds I can click be I wouldn't
watch that I'd be annoyed
what is it Sagan I'm seven and oh my
landlord is pregnant with an alien spawn
baby dis track really Oh God really
makes no sense Barack Obama got hacked
livestream yeah that one's like that's
like [ __ ] house of cards [ __ ]
okay what do you got all of the
Backstreet Boys planned my funeral and
killed me tutorial thank God oh I picked
two of this one the middle one all right
I have my boyfriend caught on fire again
get ready okay you in that way gr wlv
deviation and the must of my boyfriend
caught on fire again get ready with me
what would the thumbnail look like for
that they would just be like you was
like a bunch of fire around you and then
like a target right here and then her
just like getting dressed yeah it's like
half the thumbnail is just sheer horror
and then other half is just like a
normal gene even grw scared of you
I finally want only one that's for
winning don't shake my hand oh wait
don't do it don't do it soft like that
don't I came you all right no no that
goes over there okay
give me one of these
you always get first pick give me one
all right what do you got okay
my racist cat accidentally pooped in my
sleep parody I dunno how to phrase a
sentence like like a noun to separate
from yourself his is doing something in
there like I would have to write their
racist cat actually pooped in my sleep
parody that is a parody you don't need a
right don't go into that okay so source
said good my way from cabbage bumpkin
racist oh wait for the storytime from
your cat ASMR emotional commercial not
good not good trigger warning all right
Oprah has a basketball game tomorrow
challenge Oh as bad this is so bad
that is just horrible I don't think I
can subscribes no this game doesn't work
all right my racist cat actually proved
in my sleep parody so do we have any
left I mean we have to we have one round
left
here we go final round to determine the
winner of all the winners thank you
alright I got my mail man was robbed
story time I [ __ ] quit
Julian Matt Damon's Matt Damon turned 14
today not click did you bring this for
real not clickbait it's his 14th
birthday today
Becky [ __ ] son okay half of a team
was great though half of it was amazing
I genuinely don't know what it was I got
you guys thought we're picking out of a
cop like there's no way I could have
fixed that I'm not smart enough to fix a
game like that what the hell alright
pick a winner out of those pick a winner
top three um Guy Fieri with the boobs in
the thumbnail
would click on it 20 million are we
click on I think um let's see dead
parakeet no wait you read it a dead
parrot you accidentally sent nudes to
Michael pencil unboxing that's pretty
good actually my stepdad had allergy
reaction and peed on my butt explained
sounds pretty good
how do we pick a winner we got a pick
one keep reading them I forgot I fear to
eating 50,000 calories in one hour boobs
in thumbnail my butthole was sense
sentence of death for trafficking drugs
live footage I feel let's get rid of
them my step hamster got doxxed while
naked top 10 I get rid of my racist cat
actually pooped in my sleep parody
I'll give it alone I married a
prostitute boyfriend tag it's still
really good it's good
literally just an ant I found on the
sidewalk got arrested again crying in
thumbnail you know my stepdad already
got that Matt Damon turned 14 today not
just like disputing like straight facts
but saying like not clickbait like he's
14 today for 14 years is today and Matt
Damon any guys in 14 like but looking
like a grown adult
TMZ covers it Matt Damon turned 14 today
had it balloons at his birthday party
yeah like he you know dogs age faster
like they say every seven years is like
human years yes yeah one year seven
years
Matt Damon ages even slower than humans
please like opposite of human years I
must be sheer torture so he it's like he
was born on leap year but he ages that
way yeah basically he's had 14 leap
years damn he's born February 29th and
he's turning 14
ridiculous well I mean that was fun it
obviously needs work but I don't know
how to pick a winner how do we pick a
winner
what's our top five my dad parakeet
accidentally sent need some Michael
pencil unboxing my stepdad had an
allergic reaction peed on my buttocks
Matt Damon turned 14 today not click me
married a prostitute boyfriend that guy
Yeti eating 50,000 calories and when our
boobs in something you know what I'm
gonna say that I feel like Matt Damon
turned 14 today not pretty damn good all
right guys well for our clickbait video
winner of clickbait roulette
Matt Damon turned 14 today not clickbait
somebody out there make that video you
better click on it too and make it
clickable okay
bright colors arrows outlines come on
get the whole thing right crying
bleeding this is fun yeah I mean I would
I would want to do this again we just
have to figure out like a way to get
more maybe we need a little help yeah
totally
a little help I'll help you next then
other things do you want to hear some
Cunha jacket Thanks this one forever 21
mm-hmm it's like so soft yeah I saw it
as soon as I got in there and I was like
I need that right now I need you on my
body it's it's it's I mean it's it's no
micro model fabric though you did not I
meant the compliment it's a real
compliment it just reminded me of how
much softer knees me and these new pro
modal crew socks are guys these are the
most comfortable socks I've ever worn me
and he's just came out with socks okay
the comfortable undies that you've been
wearing on your butt if you're smart can
now be on your feet and they also have
bra let's do not tell them about the bra
that's babe yeah they're actually dope
I'm still insulted that you touched my
jacket and then segue it's a podcast no
do not touch me the bra let's are like
they're it's like having the underwear
but I mean they're hot they look really
good on you
okay you know what because the bottom
line yeah the bottom line and really
soft
Mandie socks is here okay if me undies
wasn't your thing for underwear get your
socks or bra let the socks respond from
premium materials making them the best
you can get for your feet me and ease
will be the most comfortable undies and
now socks you'll ever own guys I have I
have like two or three pairs I think of
the
but then I have the the no-show socks
first of all they stay in place and I've
worn so many [ __ ] no-show socks that
fall off or go under the heel and it
makes me nuts they stay in place and
they're so comfortable light breathable
and they still have their amazing
awesome Mandy's designs on them so right
now guys
Mandy's has an exclusive dink film
special offer for you go Mandy's calm
slash Jenna Julianne get 20% of your
first order and free shipping guys and
Mandy's is so sure that you love your
undies and socks 100% satisfaction
guarantee just order a parent if you're
not loved you get a full refund and I am
Telling You you will be in love that's
me undies comm slash Jenna Julianne to
get the most comfortable socks and
underwear and bra let's you've ever
owned also guys lift is looking for new
drivers for their ride-sharing service
I'm just looking at you I'm just keeping
tossed like itching your leg no I'm
touching I'm literally touching the tail
it I thought you were scratching your
knee pit where do I go where I go and
wide in the corner okay oh my god no I'm
kidding go mad come over here enough
lift nose lift those are their drivers
are what keeps them moving so they can
do everything to make sure their drivers
are happy in every trip like being able
to hurt earn $100 oh my god a week and
keeping 100% of your tips come back lift
is a first ride sharing platform with
tipping built-in guys and since that
features introduced hi hi ride ship ride
drivers have been paid over 200 million
dollars since that feature was
introduced and they made pickups are way
easier now because they have the
color-coded AMP sign so when you order
your lifts you have a color on your app
and you look for that color in the
windows hi oh here we go you have the
same color so it's very easy to find all
over that just your phone guys happy
drivers mean happy passengers that's why
9 out of 10 lifts rods get a perfect 5
star rating lift treats their drivers
right and that
makes everything work well because the
drivers are happy you are happy when you
take lift and now they're looking for
new drivers so guys it's a great gig you
can make your own hours if you're
working part-time at certain jobs or you
need a part-time job or maybe you work
odd hours with your existing job and you
need just a couple hours in between
where you want to make some money
lyft is great for you go to ly ft.com
slash Jenna Julianne score yourself a
$500 new Tyra bonus and get started with
the dopest ride-sharing app thank you
left Thank You live thank you me and
ease we're doing some mist can you
please do me a favor mr. connections
what can you please play some nice like
soft piano music yeah firstly Okayama so
as I said I was perusing can you
understand me in this can you understand
me in that better yeah this five is best
very systematic yeah it's not to Magica
you can lower the amount how do I do
that
and go to the next time thanks Julie
how's that that's oh that's a much
better that's better
okay so I was looking through Craigslist
for some these are all like from today
little s I'm just gonna have a normal
voice okay because their music is
distorted this one is from Starbucks in
Garden Grove manful woman this was
actually pretty sweet
what the hell it's just I can't don't
ruin the romance yeah you to the lovely
Asian girl working at the Starbucks
drive-through today on the small chance
that you come here and see this on
numerous occasions you've given my son a
butter croissant on the house
sir cute I've been keeping tally and I'd
like to take you out to dinner as a
thank you sometime let me know what
color truck I have so I know it's you oh
my god this lady gives his son of butter
Chris all on the house there okay so if
you in Garden Grove and you would get
Starbucks okay this one is called
looking for okay man for woman Orange
County I don't know if you felt it but I
felt the connection the
night I get lost and your beautiful eyes
and your smile melts me
our kids play softball together they're
on the same team we've made small talk
after I gained the courage to talk to
you if you're interested reply back with
the name of the kids team in the subject
final good so it's like you have to
reply back with some sort of proof that
you're that person yeah okay but like if
your kids play softball together I know
right that's her and it's like you're
never gonna see him again good I like
this segment Thanks
all right like and subscribe this one is
called where you lost man for woman to
the cute girl in the parking lot I saw
you walking back and forth looking for
your car lost I was smoking a bowl or
300 so know if you'd like to join me in
the future
downtown fart mister are you sure it was
a person or you just like super duper
three yep you just saw a manifestation
of a person walking by and your life
yo imma hit them up on kegs but they
didn't say what they were smoking has
just been a bowl of anything he's
smoking an acai balls okay some literal
ball I used to think I used to think
that when people said smoking a bowl
yeah
[Music]
the tiny bowl it's like a tiny cup like
a pipe all these people smoke balls just
go no one ever smokes out of place
cereal over here people might do
something wrong hey dr. felon is a nice
cocaine marijuana this one is called
flag this video this is called Lindsay
in parentheses question we're at
starbucks on bristol / macarthur man /
woman up [ __ ] okay
I've seen you a couple times sitting
with an older lady we locked eyes but I
couldn't come over and see you soon as
you were occupied not sure if anything
will come of this but I death would love
to buy you a cup of coffee
tried to airdrop my contact info but you
were too far away oh my love the smile
on the curves imagine beating on your
phone and Starbucks and all of a sudden
it's like Steve this phone number like
what kind of move is that thank you God
okay
this is called target orange Thorpe may
inform and Fullerton I couldn't keep my
eyes off your behind I know it's
terrible and rude but for some reason it
tickled me the right way and I couldn't
help but stare creepily I feel like you
kind of noticed me I caught myself
pinching my shaft while watching you oh
my god I could have gotten in trouble
big trouble honestly you're a short
latina I'll just buy the same one all
right it is it's a loop it's the thing
you ruined my reading what do you want
me to do it's just a loop it's an
hour-long loop I like the beginning ruin
my triggers you've ruined my reading I
caught myself pinching my shaft watching
you you're a short latina that ended up
smiling at me a few times but I was too
intimidated to say anything I hope I see
you there again and perhaps we can
exchange info properly oh I am a
terrible man I'm gonna start dropping my
contact info okay
I mean if I were on here buzz this woman
and I was like Oh Daniel he was pinching
his shaft working at me don't air drop
me your contact I'm sitting here playing
some beautiful piano music okay I'm not
doing anything it would be so creepy if
someone did that to me in public
yeah they're just air drop me there
contact
this one is called girl that sleeps in
her white car at Bray a dam park I've
seen you for a second but you looked hot
sleeping in your car it's a newer white
car I'm 34 good-looking
I work out here I would love to kiss you
your lips or even more let me know maybe
we can work something out Jesus Christ I
see you sleeping in your car
nothing like a normal guy is working out
at the park who's looking at you I was
sleeping well he never sees as he works
alicante ray wants to kiss her that's
not on the mouth where do you think he
was a kisser her feet all right
this one is called racing down Victory
Boulevard man for woman Van Nuys we were
in a silver Infiniti q50 I was riding
passenger light turned green and we took
off you ended up smokiness but then
slowly slowed down and disappeared this
happened on Monday September 25th around
10:00 p.m. I thought you were cute
Andrew ballsy if that's a word haha if
this is you then email me with the make
and model of your car let's get to know
each other
want to buy you dinner as a congrats for
winning and lo L
okay this one is called pregnant Beauty
at Walmart man for woman - the beautiful
pregnant woman who followed me into
Walmart on Saturday afternoon three
exclamation points
you followed me in and I couldn't help
but notice you big beautiful round belly
- exclamation mice great grandeur it
looks like you were about to pop -
exclamation points if you're interested
I would totally rub down that belly of
your with cocoa butter you have to
wonder factoids R Us or Walmart or
wherever to find pregnant women I mean
do union do you but all she did was walk
in the door after you and was pregnant
[Music]
listen dude I'm not gonna kink shame you
men but I'm not sure that this is really
a missed connection yeah well I think
you saw a pregnant woman in public was a
pregnant woman in the same place you
were I don't know if I'm gonna read that
one I'll come back to it maybe Whole
Foods San Vicente man Foreman
[Music]
you were wearing a hunter green dress
great color on you
you were at the store tonight around
6:30 just wanted to say you have the
most incredible legs I've ever seen have
an amazing weekend
guy in the mr. Rogers sweater is
complimented her legs but he was wearing
a mr. Rogers sweater what does that mean
like the style or did it have him on it
okay this one is called grey pants long
ugly shirt orange beads braids woman for
man you wait my funnel cake get at me
I'm not even joking that's all it says
oh hey shark bar
woman for men I walked up to you when
you were playing pool
I said you if you were in a relationship
you said no I didn't get your number I
hope you see this or I see you I I see
you again can you imagine walking up the
summer you in a relationship no [ __ ]
plane
hello spikes cue ball another episode
okay this one is called
del Taco where they have free Shabak
ative crucify over dere del taco man you
are the nicest guy ever
I want to make babies with you sincerely
no I don't want any ketchup or hot sauce
thank you yeah yeah they're the only
person that doesn't want ketchup or hot
sauce this one is called hot older man
and Taco Bell
man for man he made eye contact and
smiled at each other couldn't help but
to stare you were tall older man reading
the newspaper flip flops and moustache
you left as sat down
if you read the and this is you tell me
which Taco Bell this was and about what
time hopefully you see this and we can
meet finally problem with this is who
the [ __ ] reads a newspaper in a taco a
man with moustache a moustache depends
if I saw someone reading a newspaper and
Taco Bell it'd be like I would check my
to make sure it's didn't steal his
newspaper took a shirt this year this is
called Chipotle Temple City man form an
Asian man working at the Chipotle in
Temple City about 1:30 today you are
very attractive asking me if I needed
anything else you incredibly handsome
and have such a beautiful smile let's
get together what did I order and where
what was I wearing looking forward to
hearing from you it just sounds like
someone that works at Chipotle asking if
I needed any bigger USC if I wanted
white rice brown rice I think we had
something all right
here's the one that I didn't know if I
was gonna read it go for it Julian you
just you tell me when I should stop I
will pull my foot this one is called
lactose intolerant or IBS how much would
it take to get a girl with a fart a loud
nasty and stinky or take a loud dump in
front of me okay let me know respond
with something telling me about your
farts or shits or something the nastier
the better I know it's weird otherwise I
wouldn't be looking so hard send a
picture no men sorry I only like a one
women fart please don't flag my stuff
it's an honest paying thing not hurting
anyone or at least tell me where I can
put this just one so the lady didn't
take a dump in front of him it's not
hurting anybody
good for you I hope he finds a nice lady
too far in front of them and that wraps
up this week's segment disconnections
[Music]
that's Wow did you like it I honestly
that's my new favorite segment pretty
great I love that Cigna regular thing
okay not to regulate we have to find
good ones we have to find good ones but
maybe like once a month yeah that's a
pretty I like them plus I feel like
we're doing the service that's not even
yeah like for real that's if that's any
of you this is should get us very true
tell your people who post and look on
misconnections this is where we put it
on the mic yeah baby
like if you made a girl's funnel cake
yeah yeah her her it was her yeah
get out her she wants to meet you and
hang out this is a really fun podcast
yeah hey the dogs are even cheering Gaza
thank you thank you everyone
well we'll see you guys next week for
another one hope you guys enjoyed make
sure you check out sponsz and any last
thing glass parting words before they
enter their beautiful week no but if you
eat my funnel cake get at me or if you
take loud [ __ ] stop flagging myself
where can i pose
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]